with all the sequels reboots spin-offs
and occasional original films to get
released every month it can be hard to
keep track of what's actually getting
released luckily we've combed through
every notable movie release that's
coming down the pipeline this fall so
you won't have to worry about missing
anything here are some of the future
blockbusters we're projecting we'll hit
it big in the fall in order of their
expected release date Mandy it seems
like Nicolas Cage's entire career was
leading to Mandy the story follows a
mountain man named red whose girlfriend
Mandy is kidnapped leading him to embark
on a brutal Odyssey of revenge against
the polt leader responsible pretty much
everyone who's seen Mandy has walked
away praising both cages performance and
director Panos cosmatos his dedication
to making a truly insane film the movie
drops into theaters September 14th so
keep your schedule clear if you want to
see Nicholas Cage act insane in a way
only he can
[Music]
the predator kicking off a new round of
interplanetary big-game hunting the
predator finds writer director Shane
Black making a long-overdue return to
the franchise according to actor Thomas
Jane the plot will involve a group of
PTSD stricken soldiers who band together
to kill the spine cracking alien hunters
the movies got an incredible cast
featuring Olivia Munn Trayvon Tay Rhodes
keegan-michael key sterling K Brown and
edward james olmos we can expect our
ragtag heroes to face off against
everyone's favorite skull collector on
September 14th sure I reward Briley
operation finale directed by Chris Weitz
operation finale tells the true story of
an elite Israeli spy unit tasked with
capturing a high profile Nazi who
escaped to Argentina after the war with
Oscar Isaac starring as the leader of
the unit and Ben Kingsley as the
fugitive Nazi there's sure to be some
incredible acting in this historical
drama the film hits theaters on
September 14th and if you are at all
interested in history espionage or
real-life revenge stories then operation
finale might be right up your alley the
house with a clock in its walls
Eli Roth isn't really known for his
kid-friendly films but he's looking to
change things up with the house with a
clock in its walls based on the classic
children's book by John Bel Air's
this Gothic fright flick tells the story
of a ten-year-old boy who's sent to live
in a quiet Michigan town with an uncle
played by Jack Black who turns out to be
a warlock
the house with a clock in its walls also
stars Cate Blanchett and Kyle MacLachlan
and it's set to scare kids on September
21st the old man and the gun while his
films don't usually get a lot of
attention from mainstream audiences
director David Lowery has been on a
low-key role since 2013 with movies like
ain't them bodies saints Pete's dragon
and a ghost story
now Lowery is reteaming with Robert
Redford for the old man and the gun the
amazing true story of Forrest Tucker a
71 year old crook who escaped from
prison and went on a bank robbing spree
around the country [ __ ] Spacek plays
his love interest and Casey Affleck
stars as the cop determined to bring him
down the old man and the gun will arrive
on September 28th which gives you plenty
of time to visit your own elderly
relatives and hear about their wild
lives first venom everyone's favorite
spider themed antihero venom is finally
going to star in a mage
motion picture the alien symbiote is now
slated to sling his way into theaters on
October 5th 2018 with Tom Hardy in the
title role parties not the only acting
powerhouse to appear in the film
venom also stars Riz Ahmed Michelle
Williams and Ginny slay with this much
talent involved venom is at least
guaranteed to be more watchable than the
last time he appeared on screen
bad times at the El Royale sometimes all
a movie needs to do is pack in enough
talented actors for it to be incredible
and bad times if the El Royale
definitely looks like a sleazy good time
with some talented actors Jeff Bridges
Chris Hemsworth Dakota Johnson and Jon
Hamm star in the noir ish movie written
and directed by Drew Goddard best known
for helming cabin in the woods while
plot details are scarce we know the
story is set in the 60s and involves a
bunch of crooks who wind up at a Lake
Tahoe hotel there's a bank robbery a
cult leader and a mysterious
organization spying on the hotel guests
regardless were pretty excited to watch
these unsavory characters go
head-to-head on October 5th the O Royale
no place will priest first man after the
smashing success of lala land
Ryan Gosling and Damien Chazelle will be
joining forces again for first man
instead of singing city of stars Gosling
will be shooting for the moon first man
will tell the story of the space race
with Gosling playing Neil Armstrong the
first man to walk on the moon in 1969
along with Gosling Corey Stoll plays
astronaut Buzz Aldrin Lukas Haas plays
astronaut Mike Collins in the castle be
rounded out by Kyle Chandler Claire Foy
Pablo Schreiber and Jon Bernthal the
film is in incredibly capable hands so
we can't wait for first man to finally
launch on October 12th serenity written
and directed by Steven Knight serenity
promises to be anything but serene the
film follows a fishing boat captain
played by Matthew McConaughey who gets
lured into a murderous scheme by a femme
fatale played by Anne Hathaway she's
sick and tired of being abused by her
wealthy husband so she wants McConaughey
to turn the guy into shark food of
course in film noir nothing is ever as
it seems and you can't trust anyone even
Anne Hathaway serenity sails into
theaters on October 19th and judging by
the trailer the shark-infested thriller
promises to have quite a bite
the sisters brothers based on the
acclaimed novel by Patrick DeWitt the
story follows a pair of brothers whose
last name is sisters the sisters
brothers make their living killing
people and they're sent to hunt down a
chemist who stolen a formula that
reveals the location of gold the
gun-slinging siblings are played by
joaquin phoenix and john c reilly Riz
Ahmed plays their prey and Jake
Gyllenhaal stars as a minor caught in
the middle
plus there's Rutger Hauer and Carol Kane
rounding out the star-studded cast the
sisters brothers promises to ride into
theaters this fall and we can't wait to
see these actors fight it out in the Old
West have you ever had of being a fight
I've been ton of fights that's why I
figured out how to stay the heck out of
a fight The Nutcracker in the four
realms Disney is releasing their next
live action fantasy just in time for
Thanksgiving the Nutcracker in the four
realms is set to dance into cinemas on
November 2nd complete with gorgeous sets
elaborate costumes and quite a few
familiar faces inspired by ETA Hoffmann
story the plot follows a young girl
named Clara who winds up in a strange
world of talking nutcrackers
intimidating toy soldiers and scary
rodents along the way she'll encounter a
sugarplum fairy that looks like Keira
Knightley a mysterious old man who
resembles Morgan Freeman and a
villainous dictator who shares a certain
similarity to Helen Mirren based on the
trailers we can expect the adaptation of
this beloved legend to dance in a dark
direction Bohemian Rhapsody with his
flawless voice and sexy swagger Freddie
Mercury is one of the greatest rock
stars in music history a biopic has been
in the works since 2010 but the film had
multiple roadblocks along the way no one
would play as on the radio we need to
get experiments finally Bohemian
Rhapsody is set for a 2018 release date
with rami malek of mr. robot playing the
Queen frontman in addition to Malik's
own voice the film will capture
Mercury's unique vocal range with the
help of singer Mark Martel and sound
bytes for mercury himself it's taken
eight long years for Bohemian Rhapsody
to get here and when the film hits
theaters on November second it promises
it will rock you
[Music]
Robin Hood Taron Egerton stars as Robin
Hood finally bringing the outlaw Archer
back to the silver screen for the first
time in almost a decade however this
version won't be quite as merry as the
ones we've seen before
let me oh it is that's disgusting mm
18's Robin Hood is going to be like a
medieval version of Batman Begins
showing us how Robin of Loxley became
Great Britain's most famous bandit
taking Robin Hood in a dark direction is
certainly an interesting choice and with
the winning combo of Edgerton and Jamie
Foxx as his partner the upcoming action
flick could be one of 2018 s most
exciting movies Robin Hood will be
stealing its way into theaters on
November 21st
welcome to Marwan inspired by the 2010
documentary Marwan Kol director Robert
Zemeckis will tell the story of Marc
Hogan camp a crossdresser who was
brutally assaulted by a group of thugs
suffering from brain damage and PTSD he
coped with his attack by constructing a
miniature world war 2 village in his
backyard
welcome to marwan's stars Steve Carell
in the lead role Gwendoline Christie as
Hogan camps caretaker and Diane Kruger
as a Belgian which when of Hogan camps
characters come to life the film also
features Leslie Mann and Janelle Monae
and it's scheduled to arrive in theatres
on November 21st
[Music]